the retrieval that's a film that it
played it South by Southwest this year
correct and you had a leading role in it
what do you love about the film and how
beneficial was it for you to attend the
festival oh well I'll tell you that this
is an example of taking every job
because there's a job I did three years
ago and it was an audition that I didn't
want to go to I specifically remember
the day because I thought that part
wasn't right for me and I made myself
get up and go was really discouraged and
depressed that day about not working but
I went we did the film and I never heard
anything for almost three years and I
figured well you know that was a waste
and it turned out that the film was
finished and it ended up in South by
Southwest so there I am in Austin
attending the premiere of my first film
that's run at South by Southwest and it
won an award at South by Southwest and
his went on to win awards for director
and forecast at Ashland independent in
Oregon and at the Phoenix Film Festival
and running as a part of the SAG
foundations conversation series for sag
members to come and watch it so it's
turned out to be very prestigious and a
nice high level project for me but it
turned started out as an audition that I
didn't really want to go to what
factored into your decision in terms of
going to South by Southwest how was that
important to your brand I called my
manager and I said you know there's a
film that I'm a co-lead and it's running
in South by Southwest and he said you
going so well you know I don't really
know if I can work my schedule if I can
afford it this and that and he said
you're going you don't miss an
opportunity like this you're going to
South by Southwest so I went I'm really
really glad I went it's just again it's
the perception that people have they see
you itself by Southwest they see photos
of you there it it's important it
enhances your status in the industry
you